after Monaco,
the Netherlands has
the highest petrol suggested retail price in Europe
currently 2 euros 30 per liter
25 cents will be added next year
because of the disappearance of the excise duty
advantage that we had it deleted
the increase
comes back and we are at 1 price of 2
50 per liter chairman
it is no longer possible to drive a car
in this way
you may say the colleagues spring memorandum
i would like 1 general
gasoline price debate here with the State Secretary
of tax matters
to talk about that we are half of our
pay price at the pump to myth
that really needs to change
and we can slow that down together
so please 1 VAT excise duties petrol debate planar